[Música]
i
hola y bienvenidos a europa hoy el
programa de actualidad europea de france
24 en español yo soy esther herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo en bruselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy hablamos de la política
migratoria de la unión europea que lleva
años bloqueada el presidente francés
emmanuel macrón ha hablado de reformar
la zona libre de circulación de personas
el espacio schengen reforzando las
fronteras exteriores y ampliando la
cooperación con terceros países para
reducir los flujos migratorios en qué
situación se encuentra ahora mismo la
política migratoria antes de pasar al
debate hacemos un repaso de lo que se ha
hecho en los últimos años en la unión
europea sobre esta cuestión
la reforma de la política migratoria es
una de las grandes asignaturas
pendientes en la unión europea durante
varios años los países han estado
divididos en plena crisis de refugiados
en 2016 a raíz de la guerra en síria
millones de personas entraron en la
unión europea a través de las costas
griegas e italianas la meta de la
mayoría era llegar a alemania tras la
política de puertas abiertas de la ex
canciller angela merkel que prometió la
acogida de todas las personas que
huyeron de la guerra
las imágenes de miles de refugiados
atravesando las fronteras de europa
recorrieron el mundo pero también
provocó grandes desconfianza entre los
países muchos criticaron que no podían
hacerse cargo de tantas personas
aumentaron las consignas racistas en
alemania y el populismo también se
incrementó los refugiados continuaron
llegando la comisión europea aprobó
cuotas obligatorias de acogida de
personas migrantes que arribaron a
italia o grecia podrían ser ubicados en
otros países europeos para iniciar una
nueva vida
la medida no funcionó la gran mayoría no
acogió ni a una tercera parte de
refugiados
otros como hungría directamente no
aceptaron la entrada de ninguno ahora la
nueva comisión europea ha propuesto un
nuevo sistema enfocado sobre todo en
agilizar las devoluciones de emigrantes
hacia sus países de origen cuando no
tengan derecho al asilo la medida no
convence a los gobiernos y sigue
bloqueada desde hace un año
y para analizar cómo se encuentra la
política migratoria europea contamos con
los eurodiputados diana arriba del grupo
de los verdes/alianza libre europea
bienvenida diana nuestra hora aquí con
javier moreno del grupo socialdemócrata
bienvenido javier buenos gracias a los
dos me gustaría empezar primero de todo
con javier la política migratoria de la
unión europea lleva años bloqueada pero
extremadamente de dos años en 2015 2016
con la conocida como crisis de
refugiados pero los países no se ponen
de acuerdo es posible llegar a un
equilibrio donde haya más solidaridad
entre países y también con las personas
que piden asilo
la política migratoria europea común es
una asignatura pendiente llevamos muchos
años tratando de trabajar en ella pero
cada año nos presentamos al examen y no
nos echan para atrás a ver cuando un
inmigrante llega a las playas de
canarias llega a españa pero llega a
europa cuando un emigrante llega a
lampedusa a italia pero también a europa
o en la frontera polaca pues igual que
quiero decir con esto quiero decir que
es un desafío un desafío europeo al que
hay que dar una respuesta europea y una
respuesta no solo es rechazando a los
emigrantes sino abriendo canales de
migración legal pero creo que vamos a
desarrollar el tema
soy justamente
quería hablar sobre esta cuestión porque
qué ocurre con las personas que no
tienen derecho a asilo estas personas
que muchas vienen como comentabas en las
playas de canarias es decir los
migrantes económicos a personas que no
huyen de la guerra pero si huyen de la
pobreza según la comisión europea estas
personas no tienen derecho a quedarse en
territorio europeo sin embargo los datos
lo confirman europa está envejeciendo
necesitamos migración y así aunque se
han hecho algunas medidas para traer
mano de obra cualificada esto es
suficiente
no es suficiente creo que como bien ha
dicho mi colega es una asignatura
pendiente' estamos viendo que no
conseguimos no políticas que sean
suficientes para regular a esta
situación y para hacerla más humanitaria
no nos encontramos con políticas de la
unión europea que cada vez van más a
hablar de seguridad no de este miedo y
muy pocas políticas que nos ayuden a
esta libertad a esta humanidad que
tendrían que tenerlas concretamente lo
que has comentado hace tiempo que
estamos hablando intentamos impulsar por
ejemplo que hayan estos contratos
temporales que ayuden a la movilidad de
manera segura y regulada con la unión
europea y que permita a las personas que
quieran venir a trabajar temporalmente
después también volver a sus países por
temporadas que nosotros también en
europa necesitamos estos trabajadores
para para nuestras economías esto sería
una opción la hemos puesto encima de la
mesa pero no acabamos de encontrar la
manera de
cerrar el círculo legal para que se hace
javier yo soy hijo de migrantes y nunca
se emigra por placer siempre por
necesidad para mí asilo o económico son
personas ante todos son personas que
quieren buscar una vida mejor a partir
de ahí como decía a diana tenemos que
desarrollar vías legales porque como
decías las necesitamos necesitamos esas
trabajadoras y esos trabajadores la
unión europea que pasa que la coyuntura
política actual yo creo que el arco
progresista de esta casa
estamos tratando de fomentar de
desarrollar esas vías legales pero
la derecha y la extrema derecha se están
centrando en hacer una europa fortaleza
y obviamente nosotros estamos en contra
de eso porque además lo decías tú las
necesitamos y necesitamos y son una
riqueza no sólo económica sino cultural
social y yo creo que el del mundo en el
que vivimos es algo normal y no vamos a
parar los flujos migratorios por muchas
paredes o muros que pongamos en el mar o
donde sea va a ser imposible o sea que
tenemos que pensar más allá y hacer una
política holística con todas las
dimensiones inmigración legal
cooperación con los países terceros
lucha contra los traficantes de seres
humanos tiene una política global y
luego una cosa muy importante
integración una vez que están en
nuestras sociedades desde el primer día
hay que integrar les que lo que hicieron
con mis padres cuando ves llegar a una
suiza y ha funcionado
la comisión europea propuso hace ya más
de un año un nuevo pacto migratorio con
varios pelados uno de ellos es agilizar
los retornos de personas que no tienen
derecho al asilo y ha propuesto una
medida controvertida que aquellos países
que no quieran acoger a nadie como
hungría paguen los costes financieros de
estos retornos a sus países de origen es
cual es vuestra opinión sobre esta
propuesta
bueno la propuesta es nefasta yo creo
que
cogiendo la pregunta y la última
reflexión yo creo que está esta mirada
global este paraguas que tenemos que ver
los flujos migratorios que que añadiría
atemporalidad en nuestras medidas porque
los pocos migratorios han existido
siempre entonces de haber políticas que
sean atemporales en vez de estar en esta
visión holística en esta visión de
humanitaria en esta visión de flujos y
de necesidades entre los países estamos
en una visión de seguridad en una visión
del miedo del control de poner cada vez
no estos muros estas es esta europa
fortaleza más grandes más altos y más
lejos de nuestras fronteras y hasta el
punto que una medida que era una medida
holística una medida de solidaridad
entre los estados miembros de la unión
europea que era este este mecanismo de d
de repartición de personas que llegan a
europa nos encontramos con al final como
no se ha llegado en el 2005 lo vimos
estas cuotas pues no se llegó a un
acuerdo entre los estados miembros y
algunos no las quisieron aplicar vemos
como hay otra salida que es otra vez
seguridad y miedo que es bueno si no
ponemos un tema monetario entre mi
entremedio y cómo
sacamos
este verbo tan horrible sacamos de
nuestras fronteras como más rápido
las personas que llegan a europa
desde nuestro punto de vista es una
barbaridad
cómo se está afrontando el tema de la
repatriación de las personas y que quede
claro solo se puede retornar a las
personas si hay acuerdos de readmisión o
sea para que quede claro ante todo pero
yo creo que el mayor desafío que tenemos
yo creo los progresistas es cambiar la
percepción de la inmigración porque la
extrema derecha
cultiva el miedo como decía diana
es la ansiedad y da una imagen de la
emigración que es completamente errónea
cuando hablan de invasión invasión si
luego los porcentajes sin si miramos las
cifras son muy pequeñas o sea que hay
que cambiar y sobre todo nosotros hay
muchas experiencias positivas por
ejemplo hablamos mucho la 'españa
vaciada o italia vaciada ha habido ha
habido pueblos que han vuelto a la vida
gracias a migrantes y esas esas imágenes
tienen que pasar por el mundo entero y
romperles a la extrema derecha su
discurso hay que romperle ese discurso
de miedo de odio desde de intolerancia
porque porque al fin y al cabo es que
están en otro siglo en otro mundo
estamos en un mundo internacional todos
estamos conectados y vamos hacia esa vía
con lo cual hay que romper ese discurso
de la extrema derecha pero este discurso
de alguna forma ha calado en europa el
presidente francés emmanuel macrón ha
pedido que se reforme un game que se
refuercen más las fronteras exterior es
corremos el riesgo de esta europa
fortaleza que antes comentabas javier
viana yo creo que tenemos que asimilar
que ya estamos en la europa fortaleza no
vendrá no ya estamos en la europa
fortaleza y el discurso las propuestas
que tenemos encima de la mesa de la
comisión y las palabras de macrón nos
dicen que a lo mejor ya tendríamos que
hablar ya de los estados fortaleza
porque si empezamos a hablar de schengen
y de que empezamos a hablar de que
pueden haber situaciones en que las
fronteras internas también se pueden
aplicar los flujos migratorios ya creo
que vamos en muy mala dirección yo creo
que sí que en algunos países esta idea
de la extrema derecha está entrando con
tal fuerza que que partidos que han sido
tradicionales da igual sin de centro más
progresistas un poco más de derechas
están cogiendo con mucha fuerza a estas
políticas no hemos visto lo estamos
viendo ahora con macro na a vistas de
unas elecciones y nos preocupa nos
preocupa muchísimo pero sabemos que las
políticas europeas son de tres grandes
casas en la comisión el consejo y el
parlamento europeo no parlamento europeo
tendremos que ver si esta mayoría
progresiva desde los socialistas renew
en los verdes y del efsf se coge con
fuerza y nuestras políticas pueden
pueden avanzar en javier en schengen es
uno de los grandes éxitos del en europea
como puede ser erasmus sobre euro que
nació además fuera del marco
institucional europeo luego con el
tratado de amsterdam se metió dentro
y eso permite
la libre circulación de las personas que
es uno de los pilares fundamentales de
la unión europea si paramos schengen o
si lo que debe ser la excepción porque
es verdad que hay situaciones
excepcionales que hay que controlar las
fronteras son tiempos y la excepción se
vuelve vuelve a ser la regla entonces
hemos acabado con schengen y uno de los
mayores logros de toda la construcción
europea lo tiramos abajo así que hay que
tener mucho cuidado con las propuestas
que está haciendo mal con con las
propuestas que está haciendo la comisión
y con la revisión de sangin porque como
digo es una de las mayores logros que
hemos tenido en la unión europea y sería
un paso atrás
me temo que no sería el primero y el
último hacia la desintegración de la
europea
lamentablemente ya lo tenemos que dejar
aquí muchísimas gracias por vuestras
aportaciones ha sido muy interesante a
ustedes les esperamos en el próximo
programa de europa hoy gracias por ver
france24 en español
[Música]